- [Voiceover] We're on the fractions
on the number line
exercise on Khan Academy,
and they ask us to move the orange dot
to three-fourths on the number line.
Change the number of divisions
to create tick marks on the number line.
Let's see what's going on here.
I have the space from zero
to one on the number line.
If I want to move it to three-fourths,
what I would first want to do
is divide the space between
zero and one into fourths,
into four equal sections.
I would want to have four divisions here.
And there you have it, four divisions.
I typed in the number four
and have four equal divisions.
One, two, three, four.
This is going to be a fourth,
that's another fourth,
and that's another fourth.
What we care about is three-fourths.
Once again, that's one-fourth,
this would be another fourth,
getting us to two-fourths,
and then this would be another fourth,
getting us to three-fourths.
So, there you have it.
That is three-fourths on the number line.